at the end of god's creation
describing how
order emerges from chaos or being from
potential there's this strange line
which is probably the most important
line that's ever been written
in our culture at the basis of our
culture and that is that men and women
are made in the image of god and what
does that mean well if god is that which
confronts potential with truth and
courage and makes what's good out of
potential that seems to indicate that we
have the same faculty like on a smaller
scale we're not omniscient but we're not
bloody well nothing
our conscience is integrally tied into
the structure of being in some manner we
don't understand and it certainly is the
case that we take what isn't and turn it
is into what is
that's something man that's that's quite
the trick we've been able to manage and
so we're made in that image and so what
are we supposed to do
well that's what we're supposed to do
we're supposed to type our letters and
make our phrases and construct our
sentences and build our paragraphs and
put our chapters together and make our
books and communicate to people and
straighten out the damn culture and
constrain the malevolence and ignorance
that besets each of us and push nature
back and extend ourselves out into the
unknown and confront the potential
that's there in the unlimitable
quantities and make the world better
than it could be otherwise to move it
away from hell which and it can
certainly become that and toward heaven
to the degree that we can manage that
and that is a good enough goal
that's the thing you need something you
know because your life is tough it's
hard you need something that you know
you need something to get out of bed for
and fight for and that's something right
to fight let's say against hell and for
heaven
that's something to fight for you want
to be convinced about this like read a
little bit about hell
read the gulag archipelago or read
ordinary men or read the rape of nan
king or read about what happened in nazi
germany during auschwitz and all the
catastrophes of the 20th century and see
if you believe in hell
and see if you think well maybe not
having that happen anymore would be a
good idea and then think about maybe
that's something you could contribute to
then it wouldn't have to happen anymore
and that would be a good thing and god
only knows what great things we could
manage under such conditions we're
becoming incredibly technologically
powerful what would it be like if we
became equally wise
well that would really be something god
only knows what we could manage in the
next 20 years or the next 100 years you
know we're running at 40
most of us you know because we're half
in and half out and it's not surprising
because life is difficult like well what
if you were 90 in or 95
in or or all in because you're all in
anyways right it's a it's a life and
death game
no one gets out of this everyone dies
you might as well commit yourself and
you might as well commit yourself to the
highest good that you can attain because
why not it'll imbue your life with
meaning it's hard the responsibility is
there but all the meanings in the
responsibility and that'll make your
life better it'll make your family's
life better it should make your culture
better
maybe it make the world better it's like
that'll justify your damn miserable
existence at three o'clock in the
morning when you're wondering what the
hell you're doing here and that's a good
thing because there's going to be days
when you're aching and tired and sore
and there's people in your family that
are sick and you're cynical and bitter
and you need a reason to get up and you
think yeah well a little more heaven and
a little less hell maybe i can pull that
off today and tomorrow and next week and
that's worth struggling forward for
and so that's how it looks to me
need motivation watch a top 10
with believe
niche hey it's evan carmichael and i
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
jordan peterson and my take on his top
10 rules for success enjoy
rule number two treat yourself like you
matter my rule too is treat yourself as
if you're someone responsible for
helping and it's sort of predicated on
the idea that regardless of your
inadequacies and your malevolence which
you know i'm sure you have many
inadequacies and no shortage of
malevolence just like everyone else
regardless of that you have a moral
obligation so that would be a
responsibility
to assume that despite all evidence that
there's actually something
of intrinsic worth about you and that as
a consequence your duty bound to treat
yourself like that
is true
and then it turns out that if you do
that
well then your life
gets better
and and i don't mean happier exactly
although i would say it gets happier i
mean it gets richer and more meaningful
and deeper and and more worthwhile and
and you become more educated and you
become wiser and and and you treat
yourself with more respect and you're a
better model for other people and you're
a better father or a better sister or a
better mother whatever it happens to be
it's
and you're less
ridden by that guilt that's that gnaws
at you and shame
that's there otherwise saying
you're not what you could be you're not
what you could be and that's a hell of a
voice to get rid of and it's certainly
not one that's easy to ignore
so that's a pretty good
that that idea that there's something
divine let's say that resides within you
of ultimate worth
even as a philosophical statement or a
psychological statement rather than a
metaphysical statement it seems to be a
precondition for establishing
properly harmonious relationships with
yourself and that's that's man that's
worth thinking about a lot you know that
you have to because you think you could
think that in some sense you just own
yourself you know because people do kind
of make that claim especially when
they're trying to justify for example
their right to suicide
that you know it's you it's your life
it's your body
you're yours to do what you will with
and
if that was true well then it would seem
to me that life would be a lot more
straightforward because you would just
tell yourself things that you would
instantly obey and believe so first of
all you'd tell yourself all the things
that you were going to do and then you
just run off and do them which you don't
obviously because it's much more
difficult that and then you'd also say
well enough of the guilt and the shame
and the negative emotion and the
disillusionment and the vengefulness and
all those things that make life hard as
especially the self-recrimination it's
like what the hell do we need that for
and if we're our masters of our own
destiny and owners of our own fate then
why can't we just command to ourselves
that that
be dispensed with and like that doesn't
work
i've never seen anybody able to do that
so
i mean you can fool yourself for very
brief periods of time into thinking that
that might work but
but it doesn't work and and that's
strange because this is one of the
reasons i love the psychoanalysts say
because they were really the people
apart from the religious types who
figured out that
whatever you are
you're not a unitary spirit that's under
your own dominion you know
you're something like a loose
unity of a multiplicity of spirits many
of which are doing their own thing which
you're striving to bring into some form
of unity but even that unity isn't
something that's under your control in
any real sense it's it's a unity that
has its own nature that you have to
exist in relationship to and i would
also say that that's one of the things
that keeps people
people's feet firmly on the ground
because otherwise you it's easy to
become egotistical and narcissistic you
know if you if you think that you're the
center of your own being
you know in some fundamental sense then
you're only
what you're only beholden to yourself
you're sort of a self-created creature
perhaps you could think about it that
way but it doesn't work like that it's
like the ideal that constitutes the
unity that you might become
then sort of manifests itself as
something that you could strive toward
but aren't and it it it also serves as a
judge it's the thing that keeps you up
at night saying
you know there's some things you're just
not attending to and you should get at
it because
life is short and there's no shortage of
trouble that you might end up in and a
wise person would attend to the dictates
of his conscience and and
lay
out his actions in the world according
to what he knows to be true and correct
and that is how people think and it
isn't obvious that
we why we think that way that this is
part of the reason that it seems to me
so obvious that we have a religious
instinct because i can't think of what
else you would possibly call that other
than a religious instinct rule number
three be selfless the notion that our
morality is linked to our desire to
survive is i'm perfectly fine with that
the devil's in the details to some
degree
i mean one of the
[Music]
fields of endeavor that i've been
particularly struck by is uh
the work of people like franz dewall
and friends the wall has written this
seriously and also yak panceb hey i'll
tell you something cool about rats some
of you i'd like to do that
some of you probably heard this before
but this affective neuroscientist named
jacques pancep he studied rats for a
long time and he's very sophisticated
researcher and i think he was one of the
greatest neuroscientists who lived in
the last 50 years i i don't think
there's really any question of that he
might have been one of the top three
might have been
he'd be in the top three would be a
tight race up at the top three
he did this great experiment was so
smart
so
juvenile rats like to play
and they like to wrestle they like to
engage in rough and tumble play and you
might say well how do you know a rat
likes to do something it's like or
you're anthropomorphizing and the first
thing i would say to that is you should
anthropomorphize unless there's evidence
to the contrary because we share
biological platform with rats and
they're a lot like us and a rat is a lot
more like you than your stupid model of
a human being is like a human being
so you try building a rat
it's hard
so anyways you can tell rats
want to play because if you put them in
a little arena where they can rough and
tumble play and wrestle
and then you bring them there the next
time and you make them work to open the
door to play they'll work
and so that's how we know you like
something you'll work for it you know so
you can apply that to rats and they'll
work hard for it and rats deprived of
play their prefrontal cortexes don't
mature and they they're kind of
hyperactive which might tell us
something about boys in school but we
won't go into that
if you take a rat
of the same age as another rat and you
put them in a play area
but the other rat has a 10 weight
advantage
the big rat will pin the little rat and
they actually pin each other pretty much
like
dogs do when they're wrestling well they
don't pin quite as much but humans
certainly do it and pin means
dominate dominance or that's one
interpretation
you only make that interpretation if you
think that the hierarchies that rats
live in are dominance hierarchies
predicated on the expression of power
and we all kind of think that because we
use the term dominance hierarchy
but you know that's a political term as
well as a scientific term and it's
predicated on the notion that the
fundamental basis of hierarchical
structure among mammals and other
complex organisms is power and that's
wrong
it's not just wrong it's it's
corrosively wrong
it's misleadingly wrong it's like it's
seriously and
not acceptably wrong
anyways
you pair the rats once and you think hey
big rat wins over little rat
establishes dominance that's the basis
of the relationship
but the thing about rats is like people
they don't just play once because they
live in social groups that are
reciprocal they play repeatedly and
pancep being a very smart researcher
realized this so he paired
rats
to play the same rats over multiple
occasions
and the first thing he observed was the
second time the rats got together the
little rat had to invite the big rat to
play
you know and rats do the same sort of
thing that dogs do when they want to
play and
and that that play behavior is so
cross species common that all of you
know when your dog wants to play you
know you can you can take your dog and
whack him like that if you do it right
and he goes and tries to bite you but
not really right he plays and his tail's
wagging and and when dogs are playing it
kind of looks like dominance behavior
like it does among
boys because boys really like to rough
and double play by the way although
girls like it too but not as much
you can distinguish the play behavior
from aggression
and if you can't that means you never
had any friends
i mean no i mean that that's that i mean
that that's what it means it means
that's what it means because part of
being able to have friends is be to be
able to
identify aggression versus play and and
part of playing is to pretend to be
aggressive quite aggressively but still
be playing right there's a tremendous
social skill in that
anyways
the little rat has to
ask the big rat to play which i imagine
is somewhat you know humiliating for the
little rat but he's the little rat so
tough luck for him and the big rat can
dane to play and then they play and then
you can observe how they play over
repeated bouts
if the big rat doesn't let the little
rat win at least 30 percent of the time
even though he could win 100 of the time
the little rat will no longer invite him
to play
and you think
yeah it's like no
not yeah
like the emergence of morality in rats
through play
that's a big discovery man that's a big
discovery and that's there's that
reciprocity a that that exists within
the rat hierarchy and stable hierarchies
in complex mammals are not predicated on
power
so france the wall has shown quite
clearly that
you know that so chimps have a pretty
rough hierarchy and it's pretty male
dominated now barnables are quite
different we won't talk about them
because it's not germane to this
particular point but you might think you
know
the biggest chimpanzee with the biggest
teeth
he's the tyrant he's the winner
and that happens sometimes there are
tyrannical chimpanzee societies but what
dewall has shown quite clearly is that
i don't care how big and tough you are
if you don't play fair
two guys 90 your size can get together
one day when you're not feeling so well
and tear you into bits
and that's exactly what happens among
the chimps
so tyranny you know that can be a route
to dominance it can even be a route to
sexual access because it is the case
among chimpanzees that males who are
higher in the power hierarchy are more
likely to father offspring not because
the female chimps choose them because
female chimps aren't choosy unlike human
females it's a profound difference
between the two species but because the
big that more
superordinate mailchimps chase the
subordinates away
so
but dewalt has shown quite clearly that
the
males who manage to occupy positions of
authority
and competence longest in
chimpanzee hierarchies are intensely
reciprocal with the other males more so
than the other chimps in the hierarchy
they do a lot of mutual grooming
and are preferentially attentive to the
females and their infants
and so even among chimps and chimps can
be damn brutal right jane goodall
discovered i think it was 1975 another
landmark in in late 20th century
scientists at science that
and this was a real blow to to the
social construction
constructionist utopians
juvenile chimps
patrol the borders of their territory
and if they come across chimps from
other troops
and outnumber them they will tear them
into bits and chimps are unbelievably
strong and it's
unbelievably brutal and so good all
basically discovered that chimps have
the human equip or the equivalent of
human tribal warfare
and that's quite frightening if if
you're sensible because you know you
might be the kind of optimist who thinks
that human conflict is caused by
capitalism or some bloody daft notion
like that
and that wouldn't that be lovely because
then it would be you could just get rid
of it by getting rid of capitalism which
you wouldn't be able to do anyways but
you know what i mean it's but if it's
i mean we split from chimps
about seven million years ago and if the
problem of intergroup aggression is
that deep
it's a terrible problem rule number four
enforce positive behavior this is
another thing you can do in your own
household this is so useful man if you
get good at doing this your life will
get so much better you can't believe it
is
watch the people around you
and whenever they do anything that you
would like to see repeated on a regular
basis
tell them exactly what they did in
detail with you know be positive about
it obviously
and and just indicate that you noticed
and because i saw this when i was
grading student
essays you know and so i taught this
seminar for a long time and i was trying
to teach kids how to write they were in
their fourth year of university in the
honors psych program you'd think they'd
bloody well already know how to write
but they didn't
and so
i'd have them write a four page essay on
a given topic and then they had to
rewrite that to a six page essay and
then they had to rewrite that to an age
eight page essay and
the first essay i graded i it was only
five percent of their grade and i told
them i'm going to cut you into ribbons
but it doesn't matter because it's you
know five percent of your grade and so
they could tolerate that and generally
by the third essay they had written the
best thing they'd ever written in their
life and they learned so fast it was
unbelievable but one of the things i
noticed was that
they did a little testing with the first
essay they'd hand in something it was
just like
god
formulaic
boring they weren't in it at all you
know there was nothing of the person in
there there was no thought there was
just the kind of cycle babble that they
learned especially if they were in
faculties of education and
and it was dry and dull and and
everything about it was wrong and so
those are hard to grade right what's
wrong with my essay well the words
aren't right the phrases they're not so
good they're not organized well into
sentences the sentences aren't sequenced
well in the paragraphs the peregrines
paragraphs don't make a coherent
argument and the entire thing is empty
but other than that no problem was often
easier just to rewrite those essays than
to grade them you know so in any case
though one of the things i did learn was
that
even in an essay like that there is
usually like
one sentence or two sentences buried on
like page three that was an actual
thought
and reasonably clearly stated and
somewhat gripping you know it was like
the person popped out from all the
background rubbish and said
well what about what about this
and if you saw that and checked it and
said hey
you hit the mark right there the next
essay would be like two-thirds that and
that was really fun to see and then
maybe by the third essay maybe it was
all like that and then they were really
thrilled it's like wow i wrote this you
know and sort of the culmination well it
was a fourth year seminar was the
culmination of their their career as a
psychology undergraduate so that was
great fun but you can do that in your
own household if if
if
if the envious part of you isn't jealous
of the revelation of the goodness of the
person
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five confront problems for
me as a clinical psychologist
i've always looked at things i think
in some ways
from the opposite perspective of most
and maybe even most psychologists
like it's never been a mystery to me why
people are depressed
it's never been a mystery to me why
people are anxious and unsettled
it seems obvious why they're concerned
and hurt and anxious and unsettled i i
think the mystery is
how it is that we can conduct ourselves
so that that can remain under control i
mean people
deal with
very heavy burdens in their life you
know you you don't have to talk to
someone for very long
someone you might might be thinking is
doing quite well in the world and and
sometimes people are
but you don't have to scratch very deep
beneath the surface before you find out
that they have a family member who has a
serious illness or someone who's
suffering through a economic crisis of
one form or another or
or who there's some source of genuine
tragedy
one degree removed from them if it's
even removed and most people even as
individuals have at least one serious
problem that they're dealing with
and so it's no mystery that people find
it difficult to orient themselves in the
world and the mystery is
well what can you do about it and
we do know what you can do about it
and and you know
jonathan hyde wrote a book recently
now i'm afraid that it's uh the name of
the book has escaped me it's about the
college situation
and and the snowflake culture and um
one of the things that he pointed out
along with luginoff who's his co-author
was that
if you're a
psychotherapist
of any sort
particularly a behavior therapist
what you help people do is to
identify their problems that's the first
thing is to confront what's there the
reality of what's there and as bluntly
as possible and so you often end up as a
psychotherapist talking to people about
their
array of problems as it's as if they're
putting their cards on the table
and and you sort out their problems it's
like and no they often decide that many
of the things that are bothering them
are not really that important they can
wait but that there are crucial
life challenges that present themselves
to them and they're not just
psychological problems although
sometimes they are there are
problems in life right existential
problems
and then what you do is you help people
break them down into manageable units
let's say strategically and confront
them voluntarily
you know and there's an echo of that
idea there's an echo of that in in
christian thinking and the echo for that
is to pick up your cross voluntarily
which is that you have an you have a
an
unavoidable mortal burden to bear in
life there's no escape from it
except to directly confront it and to
take it on voluntarily and what's so
fascinating about that two things one is
that
psychotherapists of every stripe
understand that this is
one of the primary reasons that
psychotherapy works there's no dispute
about that among all the different
psychotherapeutic schools is that the
confrontation of
existential problems voluntary
confrontation is curative and that's
really something
and so
and and and and the practical aspect of
that is quite straightforward it it
it also indicates practical and
philosophical it also indicates to you
that
there's far more to you than you think
because it turns out that you have
substantial problems
genuine deep
problems of malevolence and suffering
but that if you
decide
that you will take that on as your
responsibility
that you can
put yourself together psychologically
just the courage and you can actually
solve the problems
and then and and that seems to be true
it's it's it's not a naive wish it seems
to be well within our capacity and i
mean that's part of the message i would
say of 12 rules for life is that
dark as things are
there's more light in you than you know
what to do with and there's more light
in you than you can possibly manifest
and
and then the way to find that out is to
to challenge yourself against these
massive problems and to find out that
you're
the one
that can deal with them rule number six
read valuable books
i don't know how many of you have read
dostoevsky's crime and punishment but i
would highly recommend that in crime and
punishment the protagonist
commits the perfect murder and he has
his reasons for it and many reasons
because dostoevsky didn't mess around
when he wanted to give someone reasons
he gave them reasons and raskolnikov the
main character had reasons for murder
and then he commits his murder and he
gets away with it
but things don't go well for skalnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the raskolnikov that you were
before you committed the murder is not
the same as the raskolnikov as you are
after you've committed the murder and
there's a dividing line there that you
don't
it's like the red pill i guess right
it's like
that's the matrix correct the red pill
and
once there's certain actions once you
take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and ruskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's a great book it's truly a
great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you rule number seven find
meaning you need that instinct for
meaning too so
and we should get this real straight
why do you need it
well you need it because life is really
really difficult right i mean
people have a rough time of it there's
plenty of suffering in life and everyone
is going to encounter it right there
you don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
you don't have to talk to someone for
very long
and and really talk to them and get
beneath the surface until you find you
know there's a tragedy or two or three
or ten lurking not very far beneath the
surface someone in the family is very
ill there's a childhood history of
extreme pathology alcoholism somewhere
in the family maybe a touch of insanity
someone has cancer you know someone some
an older relative is dying there's
financial trouble there's economic
trouble there's marital trouble it's
like life is trouble and now you know it
that doesn't mean it's all trouble but
man it's trouble and sometimes it's it's
a lot of trouble and sometimes it's so
much trouble that you can you can barely
stand it and and you see that because
people you know people get depressed and
they commit suicide and the reason they
do that is because they think not being
is better than being and that's quite
the decision you know so and and it's
not that uncommon among people who are
depressed and so it's it's it's a very
it's a very important thing to consider
and it and it isn't just a matter of
depression and suicide that's bad enough
but you know if you're unhappy because
your suffering has pushed you past the
point of your ability to cope then
there's all sorts of other things that
can happen to you that aren't directed
towards you you can become cynical and
you can become bitter and you can become
cruel and you can become narcissistic
and deceitful and arrogant and and it's
like everything's for you and then
you're out for revenge that's a nice one
i don't know against who but maybe
everyone maybe even including you
because you're not happy about the rule
you've played in generating your own
misery i mean there's a lot of darkness
underneath the suffering and so and and
that's that's an ever-present
existential danger for human beings you
know we're aware of the future we're
aware of our fragility we're aware of
our mortality it's something that makes
us truly unique truly conscious in a way
that no other creature is and capable of
things that no other creature can do but
also bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load we're the only
creatures that have to always contend
with the fact that we're finite and that
everyone we know is in the same position
that allied with the suffering and so
that's there all the time and and you
know even even in in the brightest
moments in some sense you know in in in
renaissance paintings in in still lifes
they used to put a momento
momento mori often in the in the still
life like a skull somewhere in the
corner or sometimes sometimes in in a
very strange perspective so that you
could only see the skull if you were
standing like right beside the painting
instead of dead on but the idea was to
always remember you know that everything
that exists is tainted or touched with
the with the with the with it with the
taint of mortality and you know that's
rough but there's some useful things in
it it keeps you awake and it keeps you
focused if you're careful but it also
does
indicate to you if you think about it
the necessity of having a meaning in
your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as i'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the default position and i
think it's the default position
like a meaningless life isn't
meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and i've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very
vicious turn into the darkest parts of
the underworld consequence of their
resentment and their malevolence and
then their desire to make everything in
the world suffer for the outrage of its
existence man i mean that's how we turn
things into hell if you want to know why
totalitarian states take the brutal
twists they take and why people are
motivated to do the absolutely terrible
things that they do well that's why is
that the suffering and the malevolence
that's intrinsic to life overwhelms them
and and they turn and they turn in a
very bad direction and then they make
everything that's already bad way worse
and we're very very inventive at such
things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning rule
number eight aim to serve part of the
cultural battle that we all find
ourselves
enveloped in is
partially due to the claim that there's
virtually nothing other than the lust
for power
and you know i would say
fair enough in some limited sense
which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because
you see that as a temptation that might
be powerful enough to bend and distort
you as you attempt to make your way
through let's say the halls of power
well
[Music]
i heard recently from a reliable source
that putin's conversion to orthodox
christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant issue and you may also
think it's a lie but
i would say that
i would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
worth thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
i would say
again from a clinical perspective
service to others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns i and me much more frequently
than people who aren't depressed and i'm
not saying that people get depressed
because they're selfish i'm not saying
that at all i'm saying that
one of the way out one of the roots out
of depression appears to be
an increase in service to other people
and i think the reason for that is
because we aren't power mad demons at
the core even though we may be tempted
by such things and that we find
the genuine meaning that offsets genuine
suffering
in the genuine service to others and i
think it's a big mistake to be cynical
especially prematurely about such things
as political activity because they're
necessary despite let's say their
adversarial and
and
party centered nature
partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve
and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere
victory mere
operationalized victory or instrumental
victory it's a very very difficult thing
to to negotiate particularly because in
the political realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often i
see in partisan discussion
the proclivity to assume that all the
ill will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber
and that's a big mistake and you can
think about that more deeply too is that
we all have to put we all need a place
to place the existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all
suffer from the weight of malevolent
history
right because even the grounds we walk
on here which this is a remarkable and
wonderful place i mean english soil is
soaked with blood just like the soil of
every place in the world that's part of
the human heritage and all of us bear
the marks of that conflict in some sense
in our souls partly because of the
possibility for us to engage in that but
also partly because part of the reason
we're here in all this privilege is
because of all that catastrophe
well the best way to localize that
malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing
that true source of malevolence let's
say with your mere political enemies and
that isn't to say that you won't
encounter malevolent behavior although
most of it in the political sphere
as it is everywhere most of it is more
ignorance than malevolence although
willful blindness certainly plays a
large role and so you need to know
what it is that you're serving and i
would say one of the ways to do that
practically or a couple of ways to do
that practically is you need a good team
around you the people you really trust
and who can watch you
and who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing i
would say is
you really need to listen to your
constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be and you'll
know what the problems are and you will
win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard
in the halls of let's say influence and
power
and so if you know those things if you
know you need to listen you need to get
in touch with the people you're
representing as regularly as you
possibly can and mostly to listen
um i knew a man in canada who started a
political party which is very difficult
thing to do and not only did he start it
but he wrote it to sufficient success
though that he became the leader of the
opposition in canada within about 10
years
and i asked him how he did that because
it's like well really how did you do
that that's actually really hard and he
said he would go out from constituency
to constituency and make his stump
speeches but what he really liked was
the q and a's because people would tell
him what their problems were then he
knew what the problems were and out of
the dialogue would also emerge the
answers that the audience found
compelling and so not only would they
tell them what the problems were but
they would tell them the answers they
would like to have it have have what
instituted to solve those problems
it's the same thing that comedians do
when they
when they finesse finesse their acts in
front of live audiences before they
practice them in front of a large
audience they lit they tell jokes and
the audience either laughs or they don't
if they laugh then you keep that joke
and if they don't you throw it out and
soon you're just as funny as the
audience can possibly manage and it's
the same thing you can also do that in a
dark manner by the way which is what
hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for a response and collect those
and so then you become the embodiment of
the shadow of your people
so i would recommend that you probably
don't do that rule number nine be guided
by love you speak about the concept of
the soul
do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
soul you know there's
there's i would say what we mean by soul
is something like animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well
that's actually rather easy to answer so
when a child of four is playing house
let's say when a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
perceptions in the game
what she observed her mother literally
doing so for example she didn't go into
her mother's bedroom when her mother
awoke and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blinks so that she could mimic
that in her play
and you know you think that's absurd but
it's not absurd if it's just mimicry
it's not it's unbelievably sophisticated
so what the girl does is she watches her
mother manifest maternal behavior across
a vast array of instances and she
integrates that with the image of the
mother she's received from all the books
she's been read and all the little
movies she's watched the disney movies
and so forth and she abstracts out the
animating principle of the maternal and
then she embodies that in play and
usually with a little boy and that's
practice for what's going to come later
it's unbelievably sophisticated and
she's embodying a spirit and the spirit
there is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifestation and if
you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know i had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
the mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way that would
unite the acts of benevolence across a
series of men that's all comprehensible
to you that's you take that as a matter
of course when you say that there are
such things as good men and you can
identify them right something stable
about whatever is good across multiple
manifestations of of incarnation let's
say and i saw that transform into the
the father person of the trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent spirit now
i don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but
but that
that spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people i mean it's
part of what gives someone charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something
incredibly
athletic to put the goal to put the
soccer ball the football ball through
the net
to score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a lo a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of
the depth and utility of that response
you see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated
the soul is participating in that in the
fullest extent and you know you can say
well there's no use for the religious
there's no necessary use for the
religious terminology it's like
well until you come up with a better
word there's plenty of use for it
because it's a very complex and deep
phenomena and to you know just
cast it into the realm of superstition
in some
casual manner is
it's just not helpful not in any
possible it's not helpful scientifically
it's not helpful ethically it's not
helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really i mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well i mean
what do you make of practical evidence
like that
i mean you interact with people as if
they're
free souls capable of choosing between
good and evil that's what you do all the
time
and maybe you can addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're
kind of a gambling fool and it's just
going to
make you trip over things you don't even
notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me i don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what i just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are guided by love and your
words are guided by truth annual number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is act on what you believe
human consciousness is that faculty that
confronts potential itself i think
there's good neurological evidence for
this by the way for those of you who are
scientifically minded because
we build
circuits
within us for habitual action that we've
practiced many times that seem to run in
a very deterministic fashion
and we are a strange combination of
deterministic and non-deterministic as
far as i can tell but what our
consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered
and those things that we have not yet
encountered seem to me to be those
things that have not yet been brought
into being and so you could say that
what our consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our consciousness is for the
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and then really that that's what
our consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be
you have some apprehension about
what role your choices
might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another i mean you certainly know that
there are dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that
likely
things would at least not be worse and
they would probably be better and i i
believe that i do believe that
i don't understand how this can be the
case i don't understand
how it is that consciousness
consciousness can function in that way
because i think to understand that
we would have to understand
what it means for the future to be only
potential rather than actuality and who
the hell understands that i mean no one
and then we'd have to understand how it
is that our conscious choices and our
conscious ethical choices
transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
well we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again i
would say that's a very deep idea
i think it's a i think it's i think it's
the most true idea i know
that's very
emphasized that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in genesis or in
genesis with its strange insistence that
you know god is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image
is to act in relationship to the
potential that confronts you with truth
and with courage with careful
articulation that's the logos and that
if you do that then what you bring forth
is
is good
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday
not to who someone else is today and the
reason i wrote that was because i had
this client 10 i'm a clinical
psychologist and i spent 20 hours a week
for 25 years listening to people
listening to people tell me about their
lives you know and and those people were
people who were just barely hanging on
to the bottom of the world up to people
who were so successful you can hardly
believe it like the entire gamut of
people and and that's been absolutely
fascinating it's like it's like being a
clinical psychologist if you really
listen is like being immersed in a
dostoevsky novel all the time you know
because it's amazing what people will
tell you if you listen to them they are
people are so interesting if you
actually listen to them because they're
so peculiar like they're like penguins
or rhinoceroses and ostriches they're
unlikely creatures and
anyways
um with regards to
um
to uh
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday and not just who someone else
is today um
this old client of mine he was about 85
when he came to see me and he was a
financier and a kind of a mathematical
genius he made these little pendants out
of a
a mathematical symbol for the most
beautiful mathematical equation that was
ever written that he made them out of
gold and he would hand those out and and
he had studied psychology as a young man
and he introduced me to this concept
that i didn't know about called the
pareto distribution which see i'd been
taught as a psychologist that most human
characteristics
were normally distributed right so most
people were average and some people were
extreme that that's a pretty or a normal
distribution intelligence is like that
and height there's more people of
average height than very tall or very
short and weight is like that and lots
of things are normally distributed and
psychologists tend to assume that
everything is but it isn't
creative products are distributed in a
pareto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this it's another
fundamental fact the knowledge of which
can sort of transform the way you
conceptualize let's say the political
landscape so
here's an example of the pareto
distribution huh you know there's a rule
of thumb that if you run a company that
twenty percent of your employees do
eighty percent of the work or the twenty
percent of your customers are
responsible for eighty percent of your
sales or the twenty percent of them are
responsible for eighty percent of the
customer service calls same thing but
that's not exactly the rule the rule is
worse than that the rule is
in a given domain the square root of the
number of people operating in that
domain do half the productive work
so you think well you have 10 employees
three of them do half the work it's like
yeah okay what if you have 100 employees
then 10 of them do half the work
what if you have a thousand employees
well then it's 30 and if it's 10 000
employees then it's a hundred and this
actually turns out to be a rather
iron-clad rule it it it applies across
very very many situations it applies for
example to the mass of stars and the
size of cities so you can see how
universal it is as a law and it's it's
something like those that have more get
more and those that have less get less
that's the matthew principle right to
those who have everything more will be
given from those who have nothing
everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
matthew principle and so what what that
lays out is a world that's rife with
inequality so you know you you hear this
idea that i think it's the 85 richest
people in the world have more money than
the bottom two billion that's a pareto
distribution phenomena and you might say
to hell with capitalism for producing
that it's like sorry you got your
diagnosis wrong it's a natural law
it's no matter what society you study
you get a pareto distribution of wealth
you get a pareto distribution of number
of records recorded you get a pareto
distribution of number of songs written
or goals scored like any creative
product has that characteristic and it's
partly because as you start to become
successful let's say people offer you
more and more opportunities and as you
start to fail people move away from you
and you plummet and so
okay so that's rough so what it is what
it means is that there is always a
landscape of inequality and i'm not
saying that we shouldn't do anything
about it although i am saying that we
don't know what to do about it that's
the thing you know because you can
modify the pareto distribution of wealth
let's say but if you but we don't know
how to do it without maybe disrupting
the system so completely that it
collapses which is what happened in the
soviet union for example and in maoist
china they were trying at least in
principle to adjust inequality
but the cure was far worse than the
disease and the the truth of the matter
is we actually don't know technically
how much inequality there has to be to
generate wealth we can guess and you
could say well there should be less and
you might say well there should be more
if you're left-wing you'd say less and
if they're if you're right-wing you'd
say well we'll just let the inequality
flourish but we do know that it's
inevitable and we also know that we
don't know how to regulate it so there
is inequality what that means is there's
always going to be people around that
are better at something than you are and
the and that's a that's a problem
because you can get jealous and you can
get bitter and you can get resentful and
worse you can get hopeless you know
because you look like look
i have this this friend of mine he told
me something so funny um he was he was
decrying his his lack of success in the
world and he compared himself to his
roommate
and uh
he said you know his roommate his
college roommate was doing much better
than he was and his bloody roommate was
elon musk it's like
really like it's like oh you're not
doing as well as elon musk well i mean
you can see it would take it rather
personally because they were roommates
and everything it wasn't like he was
doing badly like he was doing pretty
damn well it's like i'm not as good as
elon musk it's like yeah well you and
like seven billion other people you know
but but i thought it was instructive
because
well because you have to be careful who
you compare yourself to now you can't
just not compare yourself to others to
successful people right because then you
don't have anything to aim at
soul is also
the center of the world
which is a frightening proposition and
and not one that's easily comprehensible
solzhenitsyn's work in the gulag
archipelago is particularly enlightening
in this regard
because he insisted that it was a pre
preconception of our
judeo-christian heritage that each
person was the center of the cosmos and
you can think of that as
a center of consciousness right
a center
from which being itself is not only
reflected but also generated and it was
schnitzen's
belief and dostoevsky's as well and i
think jung would have been in accordance
with this and nietzsche as well
for that matter that
in some manner that we don't fathom
because we don't understand the
structure of the world very well
the
outcome of
the world is dependent on our choices
and and equally on all of our choices
and it i don't understand i know that's
i know that to be true i feel that to be
true
it's it's part of the doctrine that each
person is of
intrinsic and equal worth
part of that doctrine is that each
person is has intrinsic and equal
responsibility
and that we're each capable of
generating a fair bit of hell around us
and for other people but also
capable of generating a tremendous
amount of good and that the fate of the
world as it careens through
eternity
is actually a consequence of
the
ethical decisions of each of us it's a
terrifying idea
it's no wonder people flee from it into
hedonism let's say an and ideology
because it's very
frightening
possibility that
the choices that you make day to day
or fail to make
have this profound and lasting effect on
the structure of reality but i don't
really see any way out of that
conclusion one of the
things i thought about a fair bit is the
meaning of the sermon on the mount
and as far as i can tell it's it's a
it's basically a two-part
it's two-part wisdom
the first is that you should aim at the
highest good that you can imagine
and that would be a good that includes
everyone right so if i wanted what was
good for you say if i genuinely wanted
it i want it in a way that was good for
you now and good in the long run and
good for you and your family and your
community and maybe good for me too you
know you could conceive of that as the
desire and i think that's a good
definition of love is that you actually
want the best you want the best possible
outcome and in the gospels of course
that's extended even to your enemies yes
right is that okay if we're going to
have things good let's have it good
enough for even the people that set
themselves up against me because if the
world was running properly things would
be good for them too and that would be
better and it seems to me that that's a
very good way of looking at things it's
a difficult way of looking at things and
then the second
part of the sermon on the mount is
something like
having established that as your aim
which is no easy thing by the way right
because you have to be pretty
clear-headed and single-minded to
actually want that to be your aim then
you can concentrate on the day and you
can try telling the truth and you can
ally so there's truth and love that are
allied together truth love and attention
it's something like that that are all
allied together
with regards to transgressing against
the vulnerable if you're plagued by
boats of depression and anxiety that
does destabilize your identity so
it's almost by definition but having
said that
look this is when
habit
and plan
and strategy are so useful so in the
periods of depression that i've had
what's sustained some of them were long
and and and certainly the most
unpleasant experiences of my life
um
you this is when you need
a philosophy let's say that's allied
with your vision and your strategy to
sustain you because what what would
happen to me is that
i know i have these a vision and i
suppose the vision is of a world that's
better in in
that's less likely to descend into
ideological catastrophe and where people
are more responsible and more awake
and more educated and
and and healthier all of that a vision
of a better world you know a world
that's less hellish at least but also a
better world and
some sense of what role i might play in
that
and and so that's very motivating like
it's a profound goal to try to make
things better and you can do that
locally you can do that for yourself you
can do that for your family you can do
that for the broader community and all
of that's worth it man it's worth making
some sacrifices for it's worth suffering
for to some degree
and then you decompose that into the
day-to-day and week-to-week strategies
and actions that you're undertaking the
plans and and and the activities that
you're putting forward to make that
dream a reality to realize it and then
when the depression and anxiety come
along you think
part of it with depression it's like
it's just bloody endurance it's like
you get up and you
work through the next hour you try to
stay on track you try to implement your
strategic plans to the best of your
ability and you hope and you pray that
you'll get through it
you know you'll get through it and that
the darkness will recede and you
you you stay on track you eat even
though you're not hungry you get up even
though you want to stay in bed you
interact with people even though you'd
rather be alone and it's it's it's it's
the benefit of disciplined habits
can can sustain you it's like the boat
you're rowing in through a terrible
storm
leaks and all and maybe you'll be
overwhelmed but you have the boat and
you can roll forward and that's what
you've got and so endurance is a huge
part of it
and then i would say with its anxiety
it's the same thing it's like are very
much the same as you're terrified and
and uncertain but you move ahead to the
best of your ability and again you
operate at least to some degree on hope
and if you haven't got hope then you've
got blind bloody endurance
and that's all motivated by some sense
that you're working towards something
that's worthwhile working toward
you know and and that is well that's
your own long-term well-being to treat
yourself properly it's the stability and
productivity and harmony and health of
your family that's a huge deal
and then it's whatever benefit you can
be to the community
and if you have to limp along and drag
yourself forward in order to maintain
that pathway then so be it
because
it's better than the alternative
you don't have to necessarily have done
anything wrong for things to get
completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way forward
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a mode of
being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone who's capable of
standing up in the face of that terrible
vulnerability and suffering and that the
pathway forward as far as the
existentialists are concerned is by well
certainly by the avoidance of deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of responsibility for the
conditions of existence and some attempt
on your part to actually rectify them
and the thing that's so interesting
about that is that well two as far as
i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the depth by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over
decades-long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were if they
said
if they spoke their being forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 of our capacity
something i mean you can think about
this yourselves i often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done that's probably four hours right
there
you know you think well that's 20 25
hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting 50
000 a year is a way bigger catastrophe
than it would be for me to waste it
because i'm not going to last nearly as
long and so if your life isn't
everything it could be you could ask
yourself well what would happen if you
just stopped wasting the opportunities
that are in front of you
you'd be who knows how much more
efficient 10 times more efficient 20
times more efficient that's the pareto
distribution you have no idea how
efficient efficient people get it's
completely it's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that so
there's this weird dynamic that's part
of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment
both of which are are are are major
causes of suffering and the failure of
individuals to adopt the responsibility
that they know they should adopt it
isn't merely that your fate depends on
whether or not you get your act together
and to what degree you decide that
you're going to live out your own
genuine being it isn't only your fate
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with and so you know you think
well
there's 9 billion 7 billion people in
the world we're going to peak at about 9
billion by the way and then it'll
decline rapidly but 7 billion people in
the world and who are you you're just
one little dust mote among that seven
billion and so it really doesn't matter
what you do or don't do but that's
simply not the case it's the wrong model
because you're at the center of a
network you're a node in a network of
course that's even more true now that we
have social media you'll you'll know a
thousand people at least over the course
of your life and they'll know a thousand
people each and that puts you one person
away from a million and two persons away
from a billion and so that's how you're
connected and the things you do they're
like dropping a stone in a pond the
ripples move outward and they affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend and it means that the things
that you do and that you don't do are
far more important than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but i mean if
you really asked yourself would you be
so sure if you had the choice i can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price i pay is that nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are
when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well what
solzhenitsyn figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that
if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century i started to pay very careful
attention to
what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
i split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas
and there was another part that was
watching that part like just with its
eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that
you don't really know what you're
talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people
have multiple parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like well which of these two things are
me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's rubbish that's a lie
that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then
they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as the coherence between the
the the spiritual or the or the abstract
and the physical that the two things
were aligned and and there's a lot of
idea of alignment in in psychoanalytic
and clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen
adopt the mode of
authentic being
and that is something like
refusing to participate in
the lie in deception in the lie to
orient your speech as much as you can
towards the truth
and to take responsibility for your own
life and perhaps also for the lives of
other people and there's something about
that that's
meaningful and responsible and noble but
also serves to mitigate the very
suffering that produces
say the nihilism or the flea into the
arms of flea or or the or the escape
into the arms of totalitarians to begin
with
you need something to shelter you
against your own vulnerability sometimes
you know i can't sleep at night because
i'm thinking about something and usually
what i'll do is go write it down i have
some writing to do so i get up and i go
write down what i'm thinking and that
usually does the trick but because i've
been playing with youtube
i thought
well
i'll try making youtube video and
telling people what i'm thinking about
and see if that
performs the same uh function
as writing and to me the function of
writing well it's twofold one is
conceivably to communicate with people
although the fundamental purpose for me
is to
clarify my thoughts so that i know to
you know because if something is
disturbing you
what that means is that it needs to be
articulated it what it's the emergence
of unexplored territory something that
disturbs you that that's the right way
to think about it it's unmapped
territory that's manifesting itself
it's like a vista of threat and
possibility and you need to articulate a
path through it and so that's what i was
doing it's like i was thinking well this
is bothering me and this seems to be why
and here's what i think is going on and
and so i made the videos and in some
sense i i didn't think anything more of
it the next best predictor of lifetime
success is conscientiousness well so and
of the of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
and industriousness the better predictor
is industriousness so the question is
well what can you do about your
industriousness and the answer to that
is
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with this future authoring
program processes i think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself goals that
you actually value and the future
authoring program helps people do that
and basically it does a situational
analysis of it helps you do a
situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis i would
say and so the questions are something
like well
all right you're going to have to put
some effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high in eroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation
that you could draw on that you could
tailor to your own you know your own
personality but then there are
dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to auger down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control
and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates
the
so the goal well once the goal is
established and then you break down the
goal into micro processes that you can
implement the microprocessors become
rewarding in proportion in relation to
their uh causal association with the
goal and that tangles in your your
incentive reward system you know we
talked about the dopaminergic incentive
reward system and that's the thing that
keeps you moving forward and the way it
works is that it works better
if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want you want to
specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer to that has to be because
you've determined by some
means that it's worthwhile and then the
next question might be well where should
you look for worthwhile things and one
would be well you could consult your own
temperament and the other would be well
you kind of look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
so
so once but once you set up that that
goal structure let's say and that's
really in many in many ways that's what
you should be doing at universities is
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you
aim at that and then use everything you
learn as a means of building that person
that you want to be and
and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap and it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so i
was saying well you're going to try to
make yourself more industrious okay
number one specify your damn goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure so if you keep
yourself all vague and foggy
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well then you
don't know when you fail
and people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful so i'll keep myself blind about
when i fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done and that can easily
happen by the time you're 40.
so so
i would recommend that you don't let
that happen so that's willful blindness
right you could have known but you chose
not to okay so once you get your goal
structure set up you think okay if i
could have this life it looks like that
might be worth living despite the fact
that it's going to be you know
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that obviously
the goal is to to have a vision for your
life such that all things considered
that justifies your effort when i was 25
or so i probably weighed about 138
pounds i smoked like pack cigarettes day
i drank
tremendous amount of alcohol i was from
northern alberta this rough little town
up in northern alberta called fairview
and you know there were long winters
there and my friends were heavy drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on the oil rigs and you know it
was a rough town and we drank a lot i
started when i was 14 and you know um
and so
i was i had a lot of bad habits let's
say and uh
things that were and i wasn't in great
shape physically and i was also still
intellectually obsessed by as i am now
and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when i but i decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that i was
really going to try to get my act
together and uh
so i started doing that i you know i
first of all i
i quit smoking well that took a long
time because i eventually had to quit
drinking too in order to quit smoking
and i
started working out starting playing
sports which i'd never done i had a fine
time when i was a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined
i had to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them really you know obsessively since
i was
probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that
got to the point around 25 when i was in
graduate school trying to get my phds
doing all my research like i published
15 papers by the time i graduated with
my phd which was by i think by a fairly
large measure the most papers that any
un graduate student at that time had
ever published at mcgill i think that's
right might have been twice as many or
maybe twice as many maybe even three
times as many and at the same time i
wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because i
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and i couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of
my
what would you say my my
my hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
i had to stop that's a sacrifice i had
to stop
messing about and straighten myself out
because people think that the purpose of
memory is to remember the past
and that's not the purpose of memory the
purpose of memory is to extract out from
the past lessons to structure the future
and that's the purpose of personal
memory and so you're done with a memory
when you've extracted out the
information that you can use to guide
yourself properly in the future so if
you have a traumatic memory for example
that's really obsessing you if you
analyze that memory to the point where
you figured out how you put yourself at
risk and you can determine how you might
avoid that in the future then the
emotion associated with that goes away
so memory is a has a very pragmatic
function and cultural memory is the same
thing is that we need to extract out
stories from our past that structure our
future and we need that because
well first of all if you don't have a
purpose let's say
it isn't that your life becomes neutral
in a meaningless sense
it's that your life becomes
characterized by unbearable suffering
because the baseline condition of life
is something like unbearable suffering
and what you have to say against that is
a noble and worthwhile purpose and
hopefully
hopefully your determination of that
purpose is buttressed to some degree by
the wisdom of the past because you can't
conjure something like that up on your
own
and if you provide people with nobility
of purpose then they can tolerate the
suffering of existence without becoming
entirely corrupted by it and cultures
that don't do that
it isn't even so much that they die it's
that cultures that don't do that are
dead they're done
they don't have a story anymore they
don't have a call to adventure and then
well then everyone suffers stupidly as a
consequence it's a very bad thing so
churchill made the same observation that
many of the great psychologists and
philosophers made in the early part of
the 20th century it's like
bring the story forward and
and propagate it and make it the most
noble possible story and then you
motivate people to do to transcend
themselves which they need to do so yes
he's exactly right in his diagnosis
you're going to have to put some effort
into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high neuroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation that you could draw on that
you could tailor to your own you know
your own personality but then there are
dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about well you know if you could have
your life the way you wanted it in three
to five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to augur down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control
and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates
the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down the goal into
micro processes that you can implement
the microprocessors become rewarding in
proportion in relation to their uh
causal association with the goal and
that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward and the way it works is
that it works better
if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual you want you want to specify
goals that make you say oh if that could
happen as a consequence of my efforts it
would clearly be worthwhile because the
question always is why do something
because doing nothing is easy you just
sit there and you don't do anything
that's real easy the question is why
would you ever do anything and the
answer that has to be because you've
determined by some means that it's
worthwhile and then the next question
might be well where should you look for
worthwhile things and one would be well
you could consult your own temperament
and the other would be well you kind of
look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you there's an
entire what literature psychoanalytic
literature on the dangers of over
compassion hyper protectiveness
helicopter parenting all of that when
you have children you have to encourage
them you have to encourage them to take
risks
because they have to grow up and take
their place in the world you can't
protect them too much because if you do
you destroy them that's the motif of
hansel and gretel right two kids lost in
the woods
they find the gingerbread house that's a
little bit too good to be true right
it's not only shelter when you need it
but it's candy what lives inside the
house that's too good to be true the
witch that devours you
right that's excess compassion
so you don't want your mother to do
everything for you that's for sure
there's a rule if you're dealing with
the elderly and like extended care homes
don't do anything for your clients that
they can do themselves
because you undermine their autonomy
and so there's a certain amount of
harshness that goes along with that just
as there is if you're a good mother
because you have to separate yourself
from your child and allow them to make
hurtful mistakes
right i mean it's very difficult if
you're a compassionate person to stand
back far enough to let your children
take necessary risks
but one thing i'm not getting there's a
big difference between letting people do
something for themselves
and saying men should be
dangerous by dangerous that implies i
should be ready to threaten someone to
hurt somebody no you should be capable
of it
but that doesn't mean you should use it
there's nothing to you otherwise like if
you're not a formidable force there's
not there's no morality in your
self-control
if you're incapable of violence not
being violent isn't a virtue people who
teach martial arts know this full well
right if you learn a martial art you
learn to be dangerous but simultaneously
you learn to control it both of those
come together and the combination of
that capacity for danger and the
capacity for control is what brings
about the virtue otherwise you confuse
weakness with with moral virtue i'm
harmless therefore i'm good it's like no
that isn't how it works that isn't how
it works at all if you're harmless
you're just weak and if you're weak
you're not going to be good you can't be
because it takes strength to be good
it's very difficult to be good becoming
more articulate is definitely i would
say
that's the primary
array of weapons
so i mean physical prowess is something
and it's not nothing that physical
confidence that comes along with that as
well
but
same thing replicated at the level of
the ability to communicate and to think
that's a
way broader field of of battle and
opportunity
so
this is one thing that isn't taught well
especially to boys
it's more important to teach it to boys
i would say because they're more
skeptical of such of the educational
enterprise in general generally speaking
partly because they're less obedient
partly because they're less agreeable
that's particularly true for
disagreeable boys
and agreeable boys get higher grades
independent of their iq and their and
their academic achievement because
they're easier to deal with
so
what do you tell disagreeable boys
there's nothing that makes you more
formidable than verbal competence than
being able to articulate be able to
think to marshal your arguments right
some
battlefield metaphor
to get everything in order
get all your information straight
you know to marshal your forces
and so i mean that's part of the reason
that rap
artists are so popular especially among
disaffected young men black and white
alike
because they're unbelievably articulate
like they have this incredible verbal
prowess it's unbelievably attractive you
know and it's associated with genuine
artistic
and redemptive
activity
often focusing on
something that's approximately the voice
of the
underclass let's say
but a powerful voice right and it's
interesting to see how many young white
guys identify with that that's why
humility is always stressed in in great
religious traditions humility is
precisely that it's like you have to
look at
why you're not so good
yeah and and you know that that has to
break down your pride to some degree in
your arrogance it's like well that's
great because if you break down your
pride in your arrogance then you're
primed to learn and you can solve your
problems so there's nothing in that it's
a bit crushing to begin with because you
might think oh my god there's really a
lot of things wrong with me yeah but at
least then you're on the on the road to
fixing them what's the best method to
retain what you read
and to be able to use it in conversation
oh well
it's very difficult really to retain
anything without recalling it so
look if you encounter something
and then you encounter it again you can
usually recognize that you've
encountered it before that's recognition
memory so it's it's an important form of
memory it's it's
it's the memory that's associated with
familiarity but it's not the same as
being able to use something exactly it's
a rather shallow form of memory even
though it's necessary
in order to be able to use something
you have to recall it this is also very
useful hint for studying like if you're
studying and you have to remember what
you want to do is study
and then you want to write down what you
just learned so you read a paragraph you
close the book and you write down what
you remember or you read a
chapter and you close the book and you
write down what you remembered or at
least you sit there and you try to
remember because the way you remember is
by practicing remembering
okay so
if you're reading and you want to use it
in conversation
and you have to think about what you
read you have to
put it in your own words
it's often helpful to close the book and
write it down
or to associate it with some problem
that you're
currently trying to solve you have to
take the knowledge and make it your own
and then
and then that alters the structure
through which you look at the world and
that changes the way that you think so
that when you have a conversation the
next time that you're going to have the
conversation in a different way so
merely reading isn't enough you have you
have to
read and think and recall and it's the
act of recalling that produces the
remembering and it's that act of
remembering that puts that material at
hand for you let's say you want to fix
up your house
which is actually quite a lot like
fixing yourself up which is a very
common dream metaphor yeah well the
first thing you want to do is go look
around and see what needs to be fixed
you know and this the interesting thing
about that and this is akin to what
comedians do is that as soon as you're
willing to admit
comedians look at a problem and then
rise above it right away and make a joke
about it but as soon as you're willing
to admit that you have a problem
then you're you've immediately contacted
the part of yourself that's at least
strong enough to admit that you have a
problem and so as soon the act of
admitting the problem is actually the
first step to solving it yes you might
say well and it's an optimistic step
because you might say oh my god i can't
admit to i that i have a problem because
what if i can't solve it well exactly so
then maybe you won't admit to it if you
do admit to it you're simultaneously
admitting to the possibility that you
could solve it yes and then it can
actually become something that's
optimistic you can say well my life is
horrible it's like okay
but i'm doing 50 things wrong well great
i could fix those things and then maybe
it wouldn't be so horrible i've watched
the audiences very carefully and listen
to them
to see what resonates and and what
doesn't and
i think the
the the the basic argument that i've
been laying out
is that
well
we all have difficult lives you know
that life is characterized in in large
part by suffering
there's an inevitable element of
suffering in life i mean obviously
that's symbolized in christianity by the
crucifixion
which is a very harsh symbol and
um and not only is life sorrowful
in in
in part but it's also touched by
malevolence and malevolence of each of
us and the malevolence of our social
creations our societies and even in some
sense the kind of blind malevolence of
nature and
so it's it's it's it's it's a demanding
occupation to to exist as a human being
and you need
something
to sustain yourself through that it's
not optional
because the
the price of existence is so high that
without that sustaining meaning
it it it corrupts you it it embitters
you and
and once you're embittered things go
downhill rapidly you get vengeful and
and you get angry and and you get
destructive and then there's really no
limit to that and i've been suggesting
to people that
the sustaining meaning that they can
find in their life isn't to be found
through happiness let's say because
happiness doesn't work when you're not
happy when when when when things have
gone badly for you for for even for
accidental reasons but
you can find sustaining meaning and
responsibility
and you can take responsibility
for yourself
you can do that and if you take
responsibility for yourself you treat
yourself as if you're someone that's
worthy of
care
and and discipline
and then that has nothing to do with
being soft on yourself
or the pursuit of pleasure any of those
things you can take responsibility for
yourself and that works and then if you
do that properly you can take
responsibility for your family and then
if you do that properly you can take
responsibility for your community and
you can continue to
burden yourself voluntarily let's say
with with a greater and greater range of
existential challenges and all that that
does is make
more and more
and more of you
and
that
works as an antidote to the catastrophe
of life
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there